[Music] We
want to deliver this sound to the whole world. Okay, but where
is the aid? Where is the help?
Hundreds of people have
come to the world. It's still a minute. Where is the aid? Where is the aid in his lifetime? [Music] What happened to us may be the first time in the world
or has happened to anyone else in the world. It is in an
international place in the world.  There is an earthquake, and no one is
responding, with any international, united, advanced way, any
aid. Frankly, this thing has never happened before in any
other place in the world. The United Nations has failed, a complete failure. Okay, I
look like this, but this issue will not
happen in this way, and there must be an investigation into
this negligence and holding the negligent parties accountable within the
institution
[music]
Sometimes I remember we asked for aid, we needed equipment,
we wanted a lie, we wanted something like this. I was communicating with the
organizations and they told us about bags for the dead only. This is what we feel about you. The only thing we feel about you is that you
die,
but you have the right to die and we will give you to be buried in it.
[Music] [Music
]
Club
[Music]